Nancy Pelosi using a global pandemic and
an economic crisis to play politics with
Americans money and the governor of the
hardest-hit state in the country
picks a fight with the Senate Majority
Leader let's discuss those stories and
more with my next guest Republican
congressman and House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy congressman thanks for
being here
now I sent my open that four point four
million people had to go on unemployment
thanks to Nancy Pelosi delay of seven
days when there was already an agreement
on the cares Act when she was you know
pitching for Planned Parenthood and and
the Kennedy Center and the green New
Deal was I wrong you're not wrong that
was just last week while small
businesses shut down and made the
sacrifice to keep America healthy Nancy
Pelosi sacrificed the small businesses
she held it open where there were
700,000 small business with applications
that couldn't have any money but the
only part that you weren't right it was
more than 4.4 million Nancy Pelosi owes
American apology she has held up every
single bill when it came to coronavirus
that we put forth the first time she
held it up so the d-triple-c the
Democratic arm could attack Republicans
the second time she held it up for the
entire week to get more funding for the
endowment of the Arts in the Kennedy
Center and tried to put the green New
Deal and then she came back this time we
asked two weeks in advance
we saved 30 million jobs but 4.4 million
last week that was Nancy's Pelosi 's
unemployment that she added to America
but you you know congressman that is
absolutely stunning it is just stunning
to me but but I want to move on because
there are so much going on with respect
to the money that that is now being
allocated mostly for Americans who are
out of work and small businesses
obviously now Bill Maher as I said
earlier in the show asked the question
that you know how can you what do you do
we just keep printing money printing
money she of course you know says oh
this is life and death
but but we're now at the point where
some of the states are saying look
in order for us to get back on our feet
we need the federal government to make
you know to give us a clean slate so if
we've got if we're indebted because of
the Medicare system that we don't
monitor Medicaid we don't monitor
properly I should say as well as states
that have promised pension benefits to
government employees you know then
you're gonna have states that are flush
paying for states that haven't been able
to manage very well like New York New
Jersey Illinois Michigan and Andrew
Cuomo really went after Mitch McConnell
yes what I see is these liberal
governors when they didn't manage their
own states they look at an opportunity
here much like many of the Democrats
they want to grab more money but if they
would look at what we've already passed
we have passed through the house 2.7
trillion dollars and also added on with
what the Fed is doing that's seven
trillion dollars into the economy we
should allow that to get implemented and
working now the Liberal Democrats want
more but let's pause for one moment and
see what have we done for the states in
the last month we have provided more
than five hundred billion dollars to the
states put that in perspective we spend
roughly six hundred billion dollars for
the entire year when it comes to
Medicare we still have another 150
billion dollars that was going out to
the states by the end of this week so we
we increased how much we pay when it
comes to Medicaid we've went sent
directly money to them
cities bigger than 500,000 got direct
money in but the governor's got all this
money also remember what what Governor
Cuomo got he got hospitals built from
him he got Navy ships he's got
ventilators everything he ever requested
here's President Trump trying to protect
us from this crisis while you have Nancy
Pelosi just trying to politicize it she
was more interested in investigations
impeachment and ice cream instead of
focusing on what we really need to
accomplish here but but the real problem
congressman and I only have 30 seconds
left is is the fact that you know you
you see Cuomo digging his heels in st.
gee you know we've missed
manage this state and we are in the hole
politicians promising everything but the
kitchen sink to get reelected and the
rest of the country should pay for it
and I'm a New Yorker I don't think
that's fair that's not fair the federal
government has spent more than five
hundred billion dollars we had a
responsibility to help the states for
those things that affected kovat and we
have what we really need to do now is
find a way that we not only open up
these states in a healthy manner and
every state is different so you've
followed the direction then you won't
open it all at once but we also need to
open the other essential things like
Congress that's why I sent a letter to
Speaker Pelosi this week instead of
finding a way to have proxies where she
holds everybody votes in her pocket
let's open up these committees and start
working on the things we need to like
that the National Defense Authorization
or the have appropriations meeting or we
should have oversight looking at the
w-h-o which I which I think should be
renamed within with the director they
have now is the Wuhan Health
Organization these are the things we
should be investigating to keep America
safe well no question congressman
McCarthy at least start with something
in Congress thanks so much for being
with us tonight